[Applause]
it's a picking up where he left off at
Salt Lake City went out with the
Achilles injury on the best floors in
the lid
[Music]
bill and they didn't come beginning
defensively he makes it pay and it's
Melton with a steal drops it off the
plumber
as he knocks down the quick to the pass
not funny
and Milton right there hanging around
and another third see change of address
or just a role play much better in the
Clipper 2015-16 season
Booker below expands response afterwards
he was able to have some fun in hooker
wanting this one town play against a lot
of great school not mean great schools
obviously Michael Jordan's obvious but
against a lot of great school not mean
great schools obviously Michael Jordan's
the obvious in a year that he holds off
Bryant and then he just runs green
without the physical easily people don't
understand how strong he is and he's
gonna get stronger he's only 22 years
old
Stan how strong he is and he's gonna get
stronger he's only 22 years old
Quinn Snyder's before the game Monday
night he said what has really impressed
Holmes able to get that block and they
advance it ahead to Crawford hooker
coming down
[Music]
slammed it down and I think that's again
part of what got lost in the 59 points
scoring night as he takes the wings over
there rebound number eight the Sun
through feet property to Booker
[Applause]
nationally I know the Sun is growing I
know it we all know it learning how to
contort his body to take the punishment
and then get to the line
reiji's able to gather drops it off
[Music]
right now
you better bring the team yeah I guess
you could say that a double-double to
him is easy you like Devon book is gone
21:39
20 points to sleep you have 17 and 11 is
in first quarter I mean so dehydrate
double-doubles seven bottles
what about it 30 20 that's what I want
to see the food and you see butters what
about 30 20 that's what I want to see
the quote indices may the continued
office Western choppers road trip is
Booker on the Thrive flex up
a foul and the finish this is good good
and a tronic Lee these are two of the
poorest three-point shooting teams in
the league the cover says the team has
been able to get much separation booked
with the runner won't get that one goes
down gets the long rebound
soft touch all right he would have
gotten alone look at that he gets
knocked down
they don't call the foul comes right
back to him
ain't not gonna fix that we wants a
Turan ski with the cats put it in sight
look the way beyond burrito fences blue
he and Bradley Beal both hooked on it he
won't get to three the Sun get the tap
back
gimme 50 the minute two left a chance to
get this victory Devin Booker evens it
up for Vinick
[Music]